When we use the Pythagorean theorem to solve, we'll find that this distance,
from the top of the ladder to the base of the building, is 15 feet. Great
solving if you found it. But when you use the Pythagorean Theorem, we'll have x
squared plus x minus 7 squared equals 17 squared. We'll square these legs and
take the sum of the squares to get the square of the hypotenuse. Squaring these
expressions, we get this equation. We'll add the like terms together here to
get 2x squared minus 14x plus 49 equals 289. Then, we'll subtract 289 from both
sides to get our quadratic expression set equal to 0. Each of these terms is
divisible by 2, so we can divide our equation by 2. We take our quadratic
expression, and we factor it by finding the factors of negative 120 that sum to
negative 7. Those factors are negative 15 and positive 8. We set each of these
factors equal to 0, and then we solve for values of x. So x can equal positive
15 or x can equal negative 8. We know that the distance cannot be negative 8
feet, since distance is always positive. So instead, x is going to equal 15
feet. This is the distance from the top of the ladder to the base of the
building.